okay so this headline is a bit
um deceiving but back in
i believe it was 2011 guy fieri
uh mayor of flavortown got his
lamborghini stolen while it was being
serviced in san francisco
the guy who stole the car was at the
time 16 years old just like
a random kid came to the dealership
stole his car
police officers couldn't find him for a
whole year even though
there have been reports that people have
seen the car in san francisco
for an entire year kind of driving
around they finally arrested him and
he actually ended up getting life in
prison
because he also tried to kill a couple
of people
so on time kill a couple people yeah wow
oh yeah the killing will get you like
yeah
i thought they got life in prison for
steam flavor towns with lamborghini
yeah that's what the article made it
seem but no he
was arrested and given life in prison
because of attempted murder
well you know they in in the quality of
life crimes in new york city
there was this theory that people that
do little crime
also do big crime if you do little
shitty things
that you can get away with if you if
you're a shitty person
and and you you take what doesn't belong
to you and you
lie and you steal especially stealing if
you
if you take somebody's possessions
you know or whatever it might be chances
are
you are a very deeply unethical person
to begin with
like you can you can draw a parallel my
experience has always been
if you really look at a person's life
and how they live their life how many
people do they help
how are they behaving in general what do
people say about them across the board
and and you know usually those people
have a track record of being [ __ ]
so it's not surprising that if you're i
know 16 year olds do crazy things so i'm
not saying you steal a car at 16.
was he 16 at the time yeah at the time
but now he's probably older
and and you know but you sometimes
people are just
shitty and they've done some
research on even children that are sort
of psychotic
there there are there are like these
sort of
not jails but almost like these hospital
slash you know holding areas for kids
that are
so impossible that they had to be put
away from people
and the new york times did an article
about it and they are they they exhibit
even at like 11 and 12
even younger they exhibit classic
sociopathic tendencies
and i'm sure they all have shitty
parents i'm sure no not
that's the crazy thing is a lot of them
don't
a lot of them have very normal parents
with really normal siblings
but the problem is they one of them will
try to kill one of their siblings
because it gets them an advantage of
something
so there are bad eggs born and
it's a really complicated rough thing to
talk about because
you know the question becomes is are you
born a bad egg sometimes
the evidence scientifically apparently
is maybe
no the evidence shows it's most your
upbringing that's the majority
it's it's both but we definitely know
that i mean
with the majority would be your
upbringing yes yes yes 100
there are people that just are not born
with that capacity to
love and care for people or even think
about other people
well that flavor town kid's going away
for life so jesus
yeah yeah you stole a car 16 oh by the
way tried to kill a couple people
not one person but couple people
all right i'm gonna tell you this right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue okay what's gonna
happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
oh she was [ __ ] disrespected